Các bạn lưu quay hả? Chứ không phải là nhạc họng sân rồi cho mùa,
các bạn lưu quay trang mùa trang chế của vô sông má của đường nhạc.
Các bạn lưu quay là phuy trình của chúng ta là
thì mà chúng ta xam nhạc họng trên vòng mềm sâm,
chúng ta đến trường này hạc,
để chúng ta làm của chúng ta vào vòng sân đình.
Tối là chúng ta...
Càng, quay vòng đó đi nhạc họng của chúng ta rồi.
Càng nếu như các bạn đã tâm tính như vòng vòng vòng rồi, nhưng mà
được đây mình đã càng nó về dờ mình càng mà không có rất lựa hả?
Cô gần nữa, không có cái niên có gì đó mà làm bình thích mình phải thay đó.
Thả đi, những như thay thì mình phải là vô chí mình hậm mà bây giờ mình không phải là vô chí mình được của nha có tấn.